leurs ambulances jaunes est synonyme de
délivrance pour les habitants bloqués
sur les lignes de front
tara ses médecins en france d'origine
ukrainienne il a quitté la corse où il
exerce quand la guerre a commencé
il fait toujours équipe avec sergei le
chauffeur
ce jour là ils vont chercher des civils
pris au piège dans la ville d'hier keane
à la lisière de la capitale
les combats ont gagné l'ensemble de la
demande
dans ses attendus
les habitants sont conduits en sécurité
deuxième trajet premier problème
yatuu croisés
plus approcher
des combats s'engagent ta proximité
mon sens du creem veulent repousser les
positions d'artillerie russe
il faut se mettre au vert et attendre 15
20 25 minutes quand ça passe après
normalement ça craint pour ses portes
qu'aux chercheurs nationaux
[Musique]
autorisation est donnée de repartir
sergei fonce
arrivé dans in fine il s'est monté ses
enfants
troisième appel des habitants attendent
l'ambulance les troupes russes envoie
alors une salves de mortiers sur le
point d'évacuer
le premier des équipes fota race
les civils sont en face il veut les
faire monter deuxième
bo3 les un troisième
les habitants attendent pas couverts
comme les ambulances
quatrième but
il tombe dans la maison face à
l'ambulance
tard à ce cri au civil de courir dans
l'en but haut
il n'y a pas eu de blessés de retour à
l'arrière il répertorie les éclats sur
leurs véhicules sont blanches
demain sergei et arras iront sauvé
d'autres hommes d'autres femmes et
d'autres enfants à bord de leur
ambulance